هل الحضور اللافته للرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب في حملات المرشحين الجمهوريين ام
الاغتسال الداخلي بين اعضاء الحزب هو ما
افشل خطتك اكتساح المد الاحمر للصناديق
اقتراع الكونغرس
هزيمه تسببت باحباط الجمهوريين من نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه فعند الحديث عن ابرز
الخاسرين في مجلس الشيوخ رغم دعم ترامب
لهم ادم لاكسالت عن ولايه نيفادا وبليك
ماسترز عن ولايه ارينا ومحمد اوز عن ولايه
بن سلمان حتى مقاعد مجلس النواب لم تسلم
من الفشل رغم الاقتراب من حصد الاغلبيه
فالنتيجه لم تكون كاسحه
تلك النتائج المخيبه لامال الجمهوريين
فتحت الباب للتساؤل حول مستقبل الرئيس
السابق ترامب السياسيه ومواقف اعضاء حزبه
المتضاربه من وجوده على الساحه السياسيه
ولاعبه ادوار مستقبليه كانت نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه اكبر مؤشرين على ان
ترامب لا ينبغي ان يكون المرشح الجمهوريه
عام 2420 كثير من الناس يريدون دفنه ترامب
وارثه في قبر لكنه مازال فوق الارض ولديه
كثير من النفوذ السياسي بين الناخبين داخل
الحزب
هنالك ايضا مخاوف من دخول الحزب الجمهوري
في دوامه الفوضى الداخليه فقبل اشهر من
الانتخابات النصفيه هاجم الزعيم
الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ السيناتور مج
ماكونل اختيارات ترامب لعدد من المرشحين
ودعمهم في السباقات التمهيديه للحزب لكن
ما كونيل نفسه تعرض للانتقاد من قبل بليك
ماسترز الخاسر في سباق اريزونا والذي اتهم
من كونيل بانه السبب في خسارته بعد ان وجه
اموال الحزب لدعم مرشحه جمهوريه في الاسكا
ضد مرشحه جمهوريه اخرى في اطار الصراع
الداخليه في الحزب
بينما يتناحر الجمهوريون فيما بينهم صعد
اسم الجمهوري رمز سانتس الذي فاز بمنصب
حاكم فلوريدا كاحد اشد منافسي الرئيس
ترامب وصاحب الحظوظ الاكبر حسب التوقعات
بان يسعى لخوض انتخابات الرئاسه عام 2024